is it ever going to happen should I jump
off
should I change this is man and woman's
biggest question a lot of times
and the answer is you're not going to
know
the concept of a breakthrough is a
really great question because a lot of
people here are grinding and they're
asking themselves hey I wanted to have
this business or this thing
even relationships I wanted this
and now it's been a while and it's not
there I'm thinking of this from a
different perspective I'm asking you why
do you need the Breakthrough I think
it's the the people pleasing and this
not being able to say no to other people
and wanting to prove it to yourself and
to other people and you don't want to do
that no there is no proving to oneself
that's disguise too I want to prove it
to someone else Mommy Daddy like those
things and that's what we're all doing
you can't be driven
by proving it to the parent or another
person that you up you have to
find a way to do it for yourself